hello historians and welcome to south
central asia circa 280 bce
we're looking at two empires um that
occupy some of the same area and we've
got the mauryan empire here you can see
this is the expansion that took place
under ashoka around 250 bce so the
mauryan empire encompasses
the indus river valley this is today
what is pakistan over here we've got
this region that is known as gandhara
which is actually we think what the name
kandahar in afghanistan comes from today
so what we've got here is this
intersection between
two empires we've got the celiacid
empire over here in orange these are
remember the remnants this is one of
three remnants of the empire of
alexander the great uh his general
seleucus took this part of asia minor
stretching into central asia
and so this is this is the extent of
that empire around 280 bce
what happens in 250 bce is that a
satrapy of the cellucid empire called
bactria
secedes it fights a war of independence
to establish itself as its own kingdom
this is what we call the greco-bactrian
kingdoms this is around 250 bce and it
names itself bactria after the great
city of baktra which gives its name to
afghanistan's bulk province and up here
in the northeast you can see the city of
fergana which is today
in uzbekistan and if you remember from
the article about the silk road this is
the very same fergana
where the han chinese first encountered
those heavenly horses that sweated blood
now what i want to talk about is the
culture of this purple region of
greco-bactria because for many hundreds
of years this region had been passed
back and forth between
indian powers and macedonian powers
right so it has hellenic influences and
it also has indian influences and that
means we're going to be talking about
something called cultural syncretism
i'll put that down right here in the
middle of china
cultural
syncretism
and what syncretism is is a mixing of
cultural objects that's that's really it
it's it's the the mixture of cultures
and ideas and faiths follow me over here
because i am interested in talking about
the influence that greek culture had
on buddhism and vice versa
so these are two
representations of the buddha from
around the same time and in fact from
around the same region the region of
gandara near
modern day kandahar so within the
kingdom of bhaktri that we saw
sandwiched between hellenic influences
and indian influences
so both of these works are from
the first century ce
but let's talk about this footprint
because this was a pretty common way to
depict the buddha prior to the the first
century ce we we see this is what's
called an an iconic representation this
is this represents a footprint of the
buddha you can see
here some of the
the themes of hinduism
and buddhism so we've got this dharma
chakra
wheel in the center of the soul we've
got
tree ratnas here
near the heel we've got if you can see
them very faintly little swastikas
near the near the metatarsals yonder
and these are all
buddhist or hindu symbols that that
approach depicting the buddha but do not
actually
put the buddha into any kind of
human physical representation it's more
about what the buddha has left behind
so that human beings can follow in his
footsteps but around the same time in
the same region we see
this so this is a statue this is the
standing gandhara buddha
this again dates from the first century
ce from the same region of of bhaktriya
but you can see this is the buddha
wearing greek clothing this is a greek
kaiten and that's a hematon these are
these are forms of greek dress
and the buddha is being depicted in a
greek style this is very similar to the
other sculpture that we're seeing coming
out of
hellenistic cultures at the same time
and so what we see when we when we see
this gandara buddha the standing buddha
we have the combination of
buddhist faith or buddhist philosophy
combining
with greek cultural aesthetics
and indeed buddhism was practiced in
this region for many hundreds of years
and since if you'll recall let's go back
to the map
because you'll recall that fergana and
bagtra and all of these cities
throughout central asia kandahar's back
down here um are on the silk road
that that connect
the world of let's call this the west
shore to china
and you know through for ghana and
through bactra uh you could get to the
great centers of india you could get to
batali putra in suvarnagiri and have
access to
uh to the sea roots
of trade
and many historians believe that it is
through the cities of the
greco-bacterian kingdom that buddhism
made its way along the silk road to the
various
oasis cities
of central asia and from then on
into china now we see syncretism
whenever whenever cultures combine with
one another and it is said that when
alexander the great came to the
headwaters of the indus river valley
remember this is an upper pakistan um he
brought many philosophers with him to
meet with the great thinkers of the
hindu ascetic tradition
and
these the greeks called the gymnosphists
which means the naked thinkers because
these men
were so devoted to the practice of
philosophy that they they fasted and
they wore either no or very little
clothing because they felt that it got
in the way of their pursuit of knowledge
and wisdom and if you make a study of
greek philosophy you will see the impact
that these indian thinkers had on greek
philosophy during this period as well
let's talk about some other examples of
syncretism this right here is the
nestorian steel
or rather this is a rubbing of the
this is a giant limestone block that was
erected in 781 in chiang on
the imperial capital of the tang empire
in china
celebrating 150 years of nestorian
christianity if you look very closely
you can see this little cross up here ah
there you go there's your there's your
nestorian cross
see right there and you can see all this
chinese text that symbolizes the
important connection
of the church of the east to tang china
and what's interesting about this stone
monument
is the way in which christianity is
described within it
in order to proselytize to a chinese
population
nestorian christianity
uh adapted its approach to suit the the
mores of the people that lived there
right so
in this text
christ is described in
taoist and buddhist terms let me read
you a little bit of the translation
quote a virgin gave birth to the holy
one in syria a bright star announced the
felicitous event and persians observing
the splendor came to present tribute the
ancient dispensation as declared by the
24 holy men was then fulfilled and he
laid down great principles for the
government of families and kingdoms
they're talking about the messiah here
he established the new religion of the
silent operation of the pure spirit of
the triune he rendered virtue
subservient to direct faith he fixed the
extent of the eight boundaries now we're
getting into some concepts from mahayana
buddhism thus completing the truth and
freeing it from dross
he opened the gate of the three constant
principles again these are buddhist
concepts
impermanence suffering and non-self
introducing life and destroying death he
suspended the bright sun to invade the
chambers of darkness and the falsehoods
of the devil were thereupon defeated he
set in motion the vessel of mercy by
which to ascend to the bright mansions
whereupon rational beings were then
released having thus completed the
manifestation of his power in clear day
he ascended to his true station so you
can you can see the way that buddhist
thought
is being used um
to contextualize christianity and really
that's what syncretism is all about is
about taking a new idea
this thing
and putting it in line
with this stuff the eight boundaries the
constant principles
freeing the truth from dross
what these what these nestorian
missionaries were attempting to do was
take these christian principles and
recast them
in a buddhist or taoist light taking
something and recasting it to fit the
context of a new situation
you can learn anything dave it out